[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du 78 lactu en
ce 24 juin voici les principaux titres
qui seront développés 530 nouveaux
professeurs des écoles vont prendre leur
poste en septembre dans les Eveline
l'accompagnement débute dès aujourd'hui
avec une prise de contact à l'internat
de réussite éducative de Marly loi nous
étions présents seul un Français sur
deux a fait savoir à son entourage s'il
était pour ou contre le don d'organe
après son décès autre chiffre l'an
dernier seulement un peu plus de 5000
greffes réalisé sur 18000 demandes
journée nationale de sensibilisation ce
mardi notamment au centre hospitalier de
Versailles à la veille de l'ouverture
des soldes d't Philippe fleuret de l'UFC
Que Choisir nous donnera quelques
conseils pour éviter les arnaques et
surtout les recours
possibles les nouveaux locaux de la
radio LFM Mantel jolie incendié ce matin
un incendie criminel selon les premières
constatations de la police façade des
entrées ont été sévèrement endommagé
aujourd'hui la station implantée dans le
quartier du valfouret recevait la mère
de l'un des militaires français tué par
Mohamed Mera en mars 2012 selon un
dirigeant de la radio l'incendie
criminel n'a aucun lien avec cette
invitation une dizaine de syndicalistes
de forces ouvrières présents hier devant
le siège social de tisen croup à morpa
société é allemande de cidérurgie un
rassemblement en soutien à niisa Boudali
pendant 15 ans cette femme a travaillé
en tant que femme de ménage dans ce
bâtiment une activité externalisée à une
autre société basée elle aussi à morpa
SMAD elle est aujourd'hui accusée de
harcèlement moral auprès d'autres femmes
de ménage elle a été licencié pour faute
grave pour le syndicat Force Ouvrière il
s'agit d'un moyen déguisé pour supprimer
un salaire jugé trop élevé et baisser
ainsi les coût de la prestation
contactter la société n'a pas donné
suite à nos appels le procès au prudom
est prévu le 16
octobre moi je veux le sentiment abusif
il est injuste moi comme j'ai j'aime la
vérité je ve qui la vérité et
aujourd'hui je je train de chercher un
témoignage pour de V prédom qui me donne
mes droits c'est me don pas c'est pas
grave mais moi je vais jusqu'au bout
pour mes droits tout ce que je demande
nous savons malheureusement nous en
sommes désolés que nous perturbons un
peu la vie des salariés de cette
entreprise mais il faut savoir que nous
n'avons pas d'autres possibilités de
nous faire entendre l'objectif c'est pas
d'avoir de l'argent en échange d'une
violation des droits c'est de récupérer
ses droits et vous comprenez
qu'aujourd'hui toutes les grandes
entreprises sous-traitent leurs
activités auprès de petites ces petites
entreprises pour avoir être compétitive
comme on dit aujourd'hui baissent leur
prix et pour baisser leur prix font
pression sur le personnel réduisent les
effectifs et c'est bien ce qui s'est
passé dans cette entreprise comme chaque
année l'Académie de Versailles proposait
une journée d'accueil pour présenter la
prochaine rentrée scolaire au nouveau
professeurs desivelin une journée
d'accueil où les nouveaux rythmes
scolaires étaient forcément au cœur des
discussions Olivier Manis calco et
Patrick Jacques de
dixmud c'est déjà la rentrée pour les
futurs professeurs des écoles des
ivelines ce mardi à l'internat de
réussite éducatif de Marly Leroi près de
200 nouveaux profs ont été accueillis
pour une journée d'information sur la
prochaine rentrée scolaire une journée
où ils sont renseignés sur leurs futures
affectations yvelinoises orienté vers
des mutuelles ou assurances enseignantes
et où des conseils leur sont prodigués
pour éviter les erreurs en début de
carrière j'essaie pour ma part d'attirer
leur attention sur des fondamentaux du
métier leur place particulière dans la
société la relation qu'il doivent nouer
évidemment d'abord avec les enfants mais
avec leur famille avec leurs collègues
pu on essayie de les rassurer tout
simplement de le et puis de leur dire
que on a confiance en
eux qu' sont maintenant avec nous pour
un bon nombre d'années et que il y a pas
de doute ils seruront parfaitement faire
le job le job ces professeurs onont déjà
exercé entierre temps durant l'année
scolaire écoulée tout en continuant
d'être formé mais la prochaine rentrée
s'annonce différente avec l'arrivée des
nouveau rythme scolaire pour les enfants
alors à ce propos inquiet les futurs
maîtres et maîtresses une appréhension
plus pour les enfants surtout au niveau
des activités qui vont leur être
proposées savoir si ça va être
enrichissant pour eux si ça va être
ludique si s'ils vont pouvoir découvrir
des nouvelles choses et et pas juste
juste de la garderie et pour moi ça va
après je pense que ça sera plus au
niveau des parents de comment eux ils
vont s'organiser bah pour aller chercher
leurs enfants surtout quand ils ont des
enfants en maternel et en élémentaire
pour l'instant on est vraiment dans le
flou donc on peut pas vraiment dire
enfin j'aurais du mal à me positionner
on attend vraiment de voir ce que ça va
donner à la rentrée de septembre près de
530 nouveaux professeurs des écoles
exerceront dans les
ivelines toujours en éducation donc les
horaires pour les écoliers à la rentrée
2014 ces fameux nouveaux rythmes
scolaires ont été dévoilés l'inpect
Inspection académique a validé les
propositions faites par les différentes
communes vous pouvez cons consulter le
détail sur un site internet en place
pour l'occasion école par école le
détail des heures de cours mais aussi
des activités périscolaires le contenu
de ces dernières reste cependant à
l'appréciation des villes toutes n'ont
pas encore communiqué leur décision le
dossier en tout cas bien avancé se
félicite le directeur de l'Académie nous
avons eu un conseil départemental de
l'Éducation nationale vendredi soir on a
pu présenter l'état de la situation
il reste quelques communes sur
lesquelles je n'ai pas validé d'horair
on en est encore au stade comme vous
savez pour ceux qui ne proposent pas
d'horaire de leur en proposer bon on
connaît quelques endroits où ça discute
ça débat sur les rythmes de l'an
prochain mais dans l'ensemble je crois
tout tout est prêt pour la rentrée
dernier délai pour les réfractaires la
fin de ce mois de juin santé la Journée
nationale du don d'organe entre
conférence stand d'information encore
lâché de ballons en reconnaissance au
donneur le centre hospitalier André
Mignot de Versailles s'est mobilisé pour
l'occasion yolè Torz et Sébastien
combe le centre hospitalier de
Versailles se mobilise pour le don
d'organe un geste anonyme et gratuit
encore mal connu et d'après les chiffres
en France il y aurait une véritable
pénurie d'organes en 2013 sur les 19000
patients en attente d'une greffe
seulement 5000 ont pu en bénéficier de
son vivant après information et
consentement libre toute personne peut
donner son rein ou dans des très rare un
fragment 200 fois à l'un de ses proches
mais dans 85 % des cas les dons
d'organes se font chez les patients
décédés de mort encéphaliquequ six
organes principaux peuvent se greffer le
rein le foie le cœur les poumons le
pancréas et les intestins ça c'est les
six organes qu'on aujourd'hui greffé et
se rajoute à ça des tissus il y a nombre
tissus il y a la peau les cornées les
valves cardiaques les vaisseaux C
organes qu'on peut également c'est des
tissus qu'on peut également prélever dès
l'âge de 13 ans si l'on refuse de donné
il suffit de s'inscrire sur le registre
national de refus du don sinon d'après
la loi française toute personne décédée
non inscrite sur ce registre et
considéré comme donneur potentiel mais
en plus de la carte du donneur à valeur
plutôt symbolique il ne faut pas hésiter
à faire connaître son avis à ses proches
le dire son vivant c'est un que votre
positionnement soit respecté
postmortem quel que soit votre votre
positionnement et que vos proches nai
pas à choisir pour vous euh si demain il
vous arrive un accident et que vous
décédez que les les proches n'aient pas
à choisir pour vous si vous êtes ou non
d'honneur d'organ que eux n'aient pas
cette lourde responsabilité à prendre
soit beaucoup plus simple pour eux de
savoir bah oui il était pour il l'avait
clairement exprimé ou non il était
contre pour mettre un point d'honneur à
l'exposition réalisée par les enfants du
service de pédiatrie sur ce thème un
lâcher de ballon était organisé ce mardi
sur la pelouse de l'hôpital parmi les
participants la petite Zoé c'est elle
qui a réalisé le dessin de cette affiche
symbolisant le don d'organe à sa manière
donc on lui a expliquait ce que c'était
le don donc donner quelque chose et donc
elle a choisi de donner son cœur à son
amoureux et elle a très bien compris ce
que c'était le le don pas spécialement
d'organes mais après on lui a expliqué
qu'on pouit aussi donner quelque chose
de son corps et elle a répondu oui on
peut donner son sang donc voilà on s'est
dit elle a tout compris chaque année le
don d'organe permet à des milliers de
patients de voir leurs conditions de vie
s'améliorer considérablement voire même
d'être totalement
sauvé invité de ce journal à présent
Philip fleuret responsable de l'ufq
l'UFC Que Choisir sur Versailles et sa
région bonsoir Comme demain avant donc
s'ouvrir ces ces soldes d'été vous allez
nous dire comment les clients peuvent se
protéger tout d'abord les arnaques en
période de solde est-ce que c'est
fréquent encore aujourd'hui même plus
aujourd'hui fréquent tout est possible
si vous voulez bon je pense que au
niveau des des commerçants les commerces
physiques les magasins bon le le le
risque de d'arnaque est relativement
limité par contre sur Internet oui il
faut faire attention les arnaques sont
plutôt de quelle nature pour rester dans
les magasins vraiment physiques ce sont
quoi des prix qui sont gonflés juste
avant les soldes des rabais les les
gonflés c'est quand même assez difficile
si vous voulez parce que bon un article
qui est proposé en solde il doit avoir
été mis en vente un mois avant et donc
le le le le prix
de avec la le solde soldé bon il y a un
pourcentage mais c'est par en référence
à ce au prix du du mois précédent alors
si les les le commerciant a augmenté ses
prix de mois avant là effectivement là
oui ça peut être un peu alors quelques
rappels les stocks soldés doivent avoir
été commercialisés un mois avant les
étiquettes doivent avoir l'ancien prix
et le nouveau prix également qui figure
vous y faites très attention il y a des
enquêtes qui sont menées régulièrement
par par l'UFC que risque un commerçant
et puis quel recours ensuite pour le
pour le client ah ben il risque une
sanction au plan au plan judiciaire
c'est-à-dire que si par exemple service
de rent des fraudes s'en aperçoit maisut
être contané que vous pouvez saisir avec
avec l'FC enfin c'est pas nous qui
saisirons c'est c'est un la victime quoi
nous on va l'accompagner mais oui bien
sûr c'est possible et le recours alors
pour le client si on constate une
anomalie avant même une arnaque on va
commencer par appeler ça une anomalie
ils prennent d'abord contact avec vous
pour voir comment s'organiser ou
directement ils vont voir ils peut
prendre contact avec nous et puis
généralement on rela aussi avec la DCC
RF les services de la
préfecture qui de droit de la
consommation donc la fausse publicité
c'est aussi quelque chose qui qui est
assez fréquent les remises qui
n'existent pas des d'appel sur Internet
on trrouve la fausse publicité c'estàd
que vous avez souvent en page d'accueil
un pavé qui dit promotion prix choc
exceptionnel sur une catégorie
d'articles générique mais mais pas sur
un article particulier et après lorsque
vouses sur les pages vous retrouvez pas
l'article auquel vous attendez alors
comment vous faites pour contrôler tout
ça avec l'UFC dans les magasins
physiques on l'imagine vous alleever le
prix c'est peut-être plus facile sur
internet c'est c'est plus facile oui
mais vous savez il y a tellement de
d'articles et de référen que c'est faut
des services d'enquête très très
importants donc géralement on cible on
cible certains produits ou certains
articles quels sont les les articles les
plus surveillés c'est lai électroménager
c'est les soldes les soldes qui
intéressent en général puisque ça fait
un général mais c'est plus le prix sur
Internet aussi vous procédez de la même
manière vous avez des brigades qui
surveillent c'est un travail qu
comparateurs aussi système informatique
permett de faire certaines études assez
facilement alors ça ça fait partie des
des choses réguli Clement à chaque solde
on en reparle de ces différentes
arnaques même si c'est de plus en plus
contrôlé il y a des choses qui ont
changé pour protéger le consommateur
aussi c'est le délai de rétractation qui
est plus long pour les achats qui sont
faits en ligne c'est doublé maintenant
c'est plus 7 c'est 14 jours voilà ça
c'est depuis la mise en œuvre de la loi
àont qui a été promulgué et mise en
application récemment alors ça
s'applique que pour les articles enque
aussi oui tout maintenant ça a été
généralisé pour les sol et s'applique
également sur les articles qui les prod
oui qui sont vendus sur les salons ou
sur les foires aussi hein alors
qu'apparment ça n'exista sa pas il y a
pas de garantie ça fait partie des
différentes choses à savoir avant
d'aller faire les soldes demain et puis
un changement mais qui n'aura pas
forcément d'incidence pour vous hein ce
sont ces soldes flottantes qui vont être
supprimées il y avait de semaines
maintenant qui étaient librement fixées
par les commerçants ça ne fonctionne pas
forcément et du coup au 1er janvier cela
va disparaître il y aura donc un
allongement des solldes classiques de 5
à 6 semaines donc pour l'hiver et pour
l'été juste pour revenir sur sur
Internet est-ce qu'il y a des nouveaux
types d'arnaque aussi qui se développe
avec les ventes en ligne des des sites
même éphémères qui qui se créent avec
des des soldes qui n'existent pas on
rentre nos coordonnées on les perd
qu'est-ce qui apparî aujourd'hui c'est
pas vraiment des soldes c'est d'attirer
les les internautes à travers des des
des fenêtres où il y a pas toujours le
produit qui se retrouve derrière ou bien
des des des des des Rabet qui paraissent
très importants en fait pour des tout
petits prix voyez donc c'est un peu un
peu mensonger quoi et ça ça peut être
puni par la loi c'est difficile à
plaiderile c'estile pler il faut tout
cas être vigilant lorsque vous faites
vos achats mais avez-vous déjà été
victime d'arnaque lors des soldes bien
sûr c'est notre question du jour R p bah
la caisse bah tu payes un peu plus cher
que prévu donc après il faut leur
remontrer les prix pour qu'il te
rebaisse bah par exemple tu vas acheter
des chosur tu payes il disent 50 € et
là-bas c'est 55 non non j'ai pas été
victime d'arnaque je pense pas je la
sais non du tout si si une fois dans un
magasin j'avais vu au préalable des
bottes d'un certain prix et et je me dis
bon je vais attendre c'est hein ça va
être les soldes et puis en fait ce ces
soldes était devenu prix réel à la base
quoi le prix de base donc là franchement
c'était une arnaque c'était une arnaque
et ça énerve aussi les clients est-ce
que le bon réflexe c'est d'aller voir le
commerçant tout de suite non pas
forcément oui ENF on peut toujours
parler avec le commerçant bien sûr mais
bon c'est vrai que c'est frustrant de
d'avoir un article qui qui est vendu au
même prix ou ou bien l'article n'existe
plus aussi hein en général les dossiers
aboutissent lorsque vous êtes saisi de
de difficultés comment ça se passe on
rencontre un problème on est victime
d'une arnaque comme c'est quelques
personnes qui ont qui ont témoigné il
viennent vous voir VI il VI n voir voilà
et donc donc à ce moment-là bon soit le
ça sera généralement à l'amiable soit le
le commerçant reconnaît l'erreur ou bon
et puis à ce momentlà il va pouvoir
proposer un autre article ou il va
donner un avoir généralement il a
toujours une solution quand même et tous
les dossiers se règlent c'est long
est-ce que c'est long aussi non r non
non c'est assez rapide commerçant évite
ensuite cette mauvaise publicité sans
doute une fois que par contre sur
Internet c'est plus long parce que
parfois le commerçant peut avoir disparu
et là on le retrouve plus ça c'est
différent pour ceux qui voudraient vous
alerter en tout cas avoir plus de de
renseignements prendre rendez-vous il y
a un service que vous avez développé sur
Internet justement maintenant oui euh
donc je vais donner la l'adresse donc
sur notre site voilà
ufc78rdv.org et donc grâce à à ce
service donc qui est un service d'aide
de conseil en ligne donc tous les
consommateurs peuvent nous saisir et
donc avec l'équipe de jurist que nous
avons à Versailles donc nousous
engageons à répondre sous 48 he votre
travail c'est d'accompagner ou vous
menez des actions collectives également
alors on accompagne euh jusqu'à présent
c'était des actions individuelles mais
maintenant vous savez que l'action de
groupe est entrée en enfin il reste
encore quelques décrets hein et donc
très prochainement oui on pourra
intenter des actions de groupe donc et
défendre un nombre important ça de deux
jusqu'à un nombre ça ça va changer la
donne ça donnera plus de pouvoir au
consommateurs aussi bien sûr que ça Dona
plus de pouvoir bien sûr bien sûr parce
que en fait je pense qu'on l'utilisera
peut-être pas beaucoup mais ça ça ça va
créer une véritable dissuasion si vous
voulez hein vis-à-vis des des
commerçants ou des voilàà quelques
renseignements pour les clients mais
rassurez-vous il n'y a pas que des
arnaques non plus pendant ces soldes
merci d'être venu Philippe fleuret juste
pour terminer un tout autre sujet
puisque l'UFC Que Choisir va intégrer
les comités d'usagers de l'hôpital de
traape l'association fait aussi partie
du comité de des usagers de l'hôpital
Mignot ça sert à quoi ce comité c'est
des comités qui permettent aux usagers
lesit on parle pas de consommateurs
parle d'usager de défendre leurs droits
et et donc de mieux les informer
c'est-à-dire que des droits par par
exemple au niveau de de l'attente des
délais de la la qualité de prestation
des du Conseil voilà toutes ces choseslà
donc on intervient pour faire valoir le
droit des usagers vous en êtes servi
déjà de de de ce
pouvoir bien sûr alors c'est une sont
des actions locales qui se font en
concertation avec le l'établissement
hein de l'hôpital et sont c'est
responsables et donc qui permettent
d'avancer d'amener des petits progrès
par exemple sur la la prise en charge
des des malades par exemple on peuvent
se plaindre là aussi si vous avez des
des plaintes des difficultés que vous
rencontrez l'UFC Que Choisir peut vous
assister merci encore Philippe Le Fou
architecte yvelinois devant la justice
hier à versaill Philippe Leblanc 59 ans
réalisé pendant 30 ans immeuble école et
même la policlinique de montelajolie
sans aucun diplôme démasqué par l'un de
ses clients le procureur a finalement
requis lundi 3 ans de prison dont deux
avec surs délibéré fixé au 1er septembre
sport à présent le club des Archers de
guyancour a organisé son traditionnel
tir du roi ce weekend un tir comme à
l'époque il s'agissait de viser une
cible de la taille d'une balle de
pingpong nous avons suivi de jeunes
archers dans cette
compétition de la concentration pour Tao
le jeune archer n'a que 9 ans et demi
mais il a déjà compris que la pratique
du tir à l'arc m lait forcément
précision et maîtrise de
soi et cela a fonctionné sur le pas de
tir du gymnaste des droits de l'homme à
guilloncour en ce premier jour de l'été
il est devenu le roi de sa catégorie je
viens de tirer sur l'oiseau donc je suis
roi des poussins pendant 1 an c'est la
classe ouais ça représente quoi
ben un titre c'est un sport que je
pratique depuis 3 ans et j'aime bien les
ararts qui sont beaux le tir du roi est
une compétition traditionnelle qui se
déroule tous les ans et fait référence à
l'époque des chevaliers il s'agit
d'abattre une cible de la taille d'une
balle de ping ong à une distance de 50 m
pour les meilleurs de 10 à 30 m pour les
débutants et les plus jeunes avec un
ordre de passage très hiérarchisé donc
on va voir l'Empereur le
roi les les chevaliers après les archers
dont je fait partie par exemple après
les aspirants donc tous les personnes
qui sont dans le club mais qui n'ont pas
encore de de d'ordre hiérarchique on va
dire l'objectif c'est d'être le premier
à toucher l'oiseau Tao a détrôné la
reine de l'année dernière pine un sport
que la jeune fille pratique pour la 2è
année participer au tir du roi suivant
les codes de l'époque c'est quelque
chose le tir à l'art est un art
ou un sport qui est très ancien donc je
me dis que je fais
partie d'une communauté très ancienne et
ça je sais pas vraiment comment le dire
mais
c'est émouvant le tir àarc c'est la
concentration collectivité
aussi puis c'est une communauté quand
même plaisante pour moi le club des
Archers de guyencour compte 110
adhérents ce samedi pour le tir du roi
environ 70 avaiit fait le
déplacement espace Rambouillet fait ses
20 ans et offre à ses visiteurs de
nouvelles animations pour l'occasion
notamment des lectures de contes et
légendes Mathilde CERN et Patrick
Jacques de
dixm c'est un bébé
dans la forêt de Rambouillet il n'est
pas rare de croiser des personnages
mystérieux ou des animaux cocasses et le
serpent dit
j'accepte à partir du moment où tu me
portes sur le dos si tu acceptes de me
porter sur le dos tout le temps je
viendrai vivre avec
toi pour les 20 ans de l'espace rouillé
un compteur dévoile l'intimité des lieux
dans un univers magique et le roi lui
dit quand on parle au roi on doit être
plus bas que le roi moi je crois qu'il
faut croire qu'une histoire a un
côté vrai et ainsi ça donne de
l'importance à la
raconter et donc parce qu'il y a M façon
de raconter une histoire mais il faut y
croire et puis il est
redescendu alors mon oncle dit le Coro
il était tout triste parce qu'il voulait
ir DESS comme vos parents on é cont de
vous avoir vous les contes racontés par
Steven interroge sur le rapport entre
animaux et êtres humains sa
particularité faire intervenir le public
un moment de détente pour les petits
comme pour les grands c'était très bien
j'ai bien aimé ce compte j'étais le
poisson et puis j'ai suivi le héros il
m'a porté il a volé il m'a posé dans
l'autre étant et puis il m'a
mangé et tu entends souvent des comptes
tu aimes bien les comptes comme ça
beaucoup moi aussi je l'ai bien aimé
comme ma fille ou donc nous on on écoute
un peu souvent les comptes es ont
beaucoup de livres sur les compes comp
Andersen compte GRI tout ça donc c'éit
assez sympa je trouve que c'est c'est
bien d'avoir des comptes pour enfant
c'est important de pour l'entretien leur
imagination Steven continue à narrer les
dimanches 6 juillet et 10 août toutes
les his ont un jour une fin si moi je
veux raconter encore une histoire ça en
ferit trop aussi on va s'arrêter
là merci merci de nous avoir suivi sur
TVfil 78 prochaine édition du 78 lactu
demain même heure ce journal est à
retrouver en intégralité sur notre site
Internet grâce au replay excellente
[Musique]
soirée